okay so in all honesty it's a little
hard to talk about Oliver and company
without talking about another animated
film that came out the exact same
weekend the Land Before Time when I was
a kid
Oliver and company was the movie I
wanted to see I heard the Billy Joel
songs I saw the animation I saw the cool
dogs I saw in New York it just looks
like an awesome movie but it was sold
out at the time and my folks could only
get tickets to the Land Before Time okay
well I guess I can see that in the Land
Before Time as most of you know was a
really great Vil the animation was great
the story was great and it was very
disney-esque but we're not reviewing
that we're reviewing Oliver accompanied
the film I really wanted to see is a
little kid so next week we got our
tickets set on down and after Land
Before Time this was really
underwhelming I know it's weird saying
that even as I'm an adult talking about
this and reviewing it again but the
reason I bring it up is because The Land
Before Time was much more like a Disney
film than Oliver and company was it did
a much better job teaching life lessons
with really heavy scenes and well really
memorable characters Oliver and company
definitely seemed like a marketing tool
even as a kid I sort of felt manipulated
by it in fact I actually remember
enjoying the toys much more than I
remember enjoying the movie yeah I had a
Cheech Marin dog what about it well
anyway let's get to the actual story
it's the basic Oliver Twist story except
with animals then it doesn't take place
in the time of Charles Dickens it takes
place in modern-day New York City here
that's catchy drawn style actually has a
little bit more of all it's not it looks
like an etching you'd see maybe in a New
York store or a fine art store or
something like that in this version
Oliver isn't a boy he's a kitten and
Dodger isn't a boy either he's a dog but
not just a dog a grownup dog voiced by
Billy Joel in terms of the Oliver story
I really find that distracting I liked
how Dodger and Oliver's are had a
connection how they were sort of the
same age and blah-blah-blah-blah-blah if
I'm gonna connect this to the original
Oliver's story I'm gonna be really
disappointed there's really no point in
setting it in modern day or in New York
with animals so let's just ignore that
for now look at the story as it is
Oliver meets up with a bunch of tough
dogs were owned by this bum voiced by
Dom DeLuise he does dealings with this
gangster but not because he wants to
more because he just got himself in a
bad situation much like Oliver Twist
though Oliver finds himself in the hands
of a much nicer family and he's
constantly flip-flopping back and forth
throughout the entire film the nice
family has a dog voice by Ben Midler and
of course she gets a song Chrissy is
nice spawn field it's just pretty
perfect
eventually it ends up in this kind of
complicated story about kidnapping the
little girl and now Oliver in the gang
have to go save her I guess it leads to
kind of a neat climax and actually one
of the best villain deaths ever I
literally remember nothing about this
villain except how he dies watch this
that is awesome
aside from that the movie only has a few
things to offer one is that goddamn
catchy song and it is catchy you'll be
humming it all day once you watch this
review what surprisingly I don't think
the other songs are very catchy I think
they just had this one big hit and they
just exploited it like mad I do remember
Cheech Marin as the Chihuahua yeah he
gets a funny line every once in a while
it's funny thinking he'd come back as a
hyena a few years later and actually I
really do like the way they portray New
York after finally having been there I
gotta say it's pretty close to accurate
it's big but it's tight there's a lot of
attitude but there's a lot of character
too from an animation point of view I
think they got it down spot-on aside
from that it's surprisingly forgettable
I don't remember too many of the
characters and like I said the songs
don't really leave you humming much
except for the one and yeah for Disney
to do a version of Oliver I sort of
expected a lot more than this at least
for it to make a bigger impact but again
it's not awful it's just strange
thinking that the non Disney film at the
time was turning out the much better
Disney product if you're an animal
person maybe you'll get into some of the
cute eNOS of it but aside from that it's
nothing to scream about well let's face
it this was just the film to tide us
over before the next gigantic hint